mr. Falcon so you guys voted on my
Facebook page for you for all four
diehards I'm gonna keep doing this to at
the end of serve you I'm going to
propose another set of reviews that you
may vote on the die hard films I grew up
watching the die art films I've always
enjoyed them so let's start right off
with die hard number one within this
skyscraper high above the city twelve
terrorists have declared war fair amount
between their is brilliant because I
have interests in a six hundred and
forty million dollars Oh
first I heart is an action classic it is
widely regarded as the Mac Shenmue II
that basically spawned the Common Era of
action films you know the one lone guy
he's vulnerable you know similar to
Indiana Jones how he was just a
vulnerable here he wasn't a perfect hero
like Rambo just comes and killed
everyone around the best but no guy gets
his butt kicked all the time the only
thing he can survive on is his
cleverness and his ingenuity no the last
thing McLean wants steak steak is to be
a hero
but he doesn't have a choice what does
he think he's doing John we just kind of
messes everything up for the terrorists
and it's so entertaining to watch this
is really the movie that catapulted
Bruce Willis to start him and he is just
fantastic in this film as an action star
he is so believable he's very intense
his acting is very good very funny John
McTiernan as a director he directed
predator he's a very good actual
director he's very sure handed with the
camera all the way through the film
tension just tension just strained to
the absolute possible max of what you
could get out of the situation
double jeopardy
do anything you have a chance against us
cowboy kike
Alan Rickman is fantastic as the villain
he is just so so good has so many great
lines now I have machine gun
ho ho ho it's one of the greatest action
movies ever made diehard number one four
stars for sure he's an easy guy to like
come on to the coast get together have a
few laughs and a hard man to kill Bruce
Willis die hard now on the die hard -
there's panic in the air professional
mercenary you got the world's biggest
drug dealer on his way here now what do
you need a slide rule to figure this out
you get the hell out of my office before
I throw you out of my damn airport this
one changes directors and goes to Renny
Harlin this film has him once again at
Christmas time battling terrorists but
this time these terrorists are hijacking
a whole bunch of planes a lot of lives
in danger a lot of flights are being
diverted by these terrorists with with
people who are on the planes danger of
running out of fuel John McClane's in
the situation where all the people on
the grounds basically don't believe him
Who I am is unimportant what I want is
very important we are just up to our
neck and terrorists again John but for
police officer John McClane right it's
just another Christmas wrong guy in the
wrong place at the wrong time
stow in my life
tie her to is my least favorite out of
the four however I still enjoy it it's a
very good action film has a lot of
sustained tension but the weakest thing
for me is really some of the characters
John McClane is still great his
character you know he's still funny but
all the supporting characters you know
the other cops that this was one guy
forget his name but he's from this old
show han white PD blue he just annoys me
he's just so over the top the bill is
pretty good flash tight get through you
through the back wall of the theater got
a cowboy ride too rough I don't like to
fly
this time
it'll show you sky high which just
doesn't have the same intensity of the
first one although the action is still
really well done it's just not as well
written and/or is actually interesting
as the first one was and the villain is
not as strong as Alan Rickman wasn't the
first one however die hard 2 is still a
fun experience and I'm going to give it
three out of four stars is what you
expected know just the beginning on July
4th die harder
moving on to die hard with a vengeance
in the hands of a mastermind of terror I
want to play a game with lieutenant
McClane what kinda game Simon Says
the best revenge bleach straight to John
McClane this one was actually directed
again by John McTiernan who returned
from the first one which is a very
welcome addition I actually loved ir3
all the way through a completely
fast-paced it's really well done once it
gets to the finale it seems sort of
separated from the rest of the movie but
all the way up and through through then
Samuel Jackson is so good as the
sidekick Bruce Willis his character
seems like he's the same character from
the first one like it's just it's it's
really good John McTiernan understands
that character and a whole movie takes
place in one day which is really cool so
even when the action is it happening and
the characters are just talking you're
still in that scene like you're in the
action of that moment what is he gonna
do with me I have no idea you just said
it had to be you it's nice to be needed
Simon Says get to the paper in Wall
Street Station by 10:20 was another
three train and it's passengers and
vaporise I'm not jumping through hoops
for some psycho that's a white man with
white problems you deal with
god knows what they're doing this guy
wants to pound on YouTube you crumble
are you anybody people know well maybe
that mime Jeremy Irons plays a villain
in that film and he does a very good job
he's considerably better than going and
ir-2 it's just a really great fast-paced
film and I actually like even more than
the first one until the finale which
just seems rid separated from the rest
of the film and wasn't as intense so I'm
going to give diehard three three and a
half out of four stars
who's Willis Jeremy Irons samuel
l.jackson congratulations you're still
alive it became
in a John McTiernan film die hard with a
vengeance we on to live free or die hard
not take it from you
you just killed a helicopter with a car
how's that bullets this was a movie that
just came out way after three it was
rated pg-13 tons people more mad about
that everyone thought it's gonna be
horrible but it wasn't it was actually a
very good sequel I don't like it as much
as diehard 3 but I think it's a lot
better than 2 Bruce Willis is just so
fun in this movie and Justin Long wasn't
that bad and I really liked him at the
Oliphant as the villain I like him as an
actor overall really surprised a lot of
people because it was able to maintain
that same diehard feel without the R
rating the action on that film is
fantastic Bruce Willis is great problem
is very real because you feel the threat
of the electronic terrorism in this day
and age that's something that a lot of
people are worried about so it seems
more real
so check in hold on a minute so he's
coming around
I thought I did it has a lot of good
humor fantastic action even though it's
over the top at all the die hard movies
are over the top so I'm going to give a
live free or die are three and a half
out of four stars I really like the die
hard films and supposedly they're making
a fifth one I'm looking forward to it
hey my shirt
did you want to say something okay
why'd you bring a cop into my command
center hahaha comrades better debasement
who is this man so I'm gonna give you
guys an ultimatum here you can have me
either review Independence Day or
predator I'm going to leave two comments
with predator and one with Independence
Day
you guys can thumbs them up which one
you want